>>Teacher: We started from day
one, the first day of school,
talking to the students about how
do they want their school to be,
how do they want their
classroom to be?
What does it look like,
feel like and sound like?
We talk a lot about being
respectful, so the students know,
when they're in the
hall, other classes are
in their room, and they're learning.
So if we're loud, we're interrupting
them, they're not being respectful.
So we talk a lot about
helping the students.
We want the students to
understand why there are norms,
and why there are rules,
and there is consistency
across the building,
from our staff members.
>>When I got the job,
and became principal,
I met with every staff
member individually
and asked them what their
vision was for the school.
Where did they want the school
to go, and then what were--
how did they think
we could get there?
And based on their results, even
though I had my ideas in my mind,
but based on their results, we
started forming committees and teams,
we had a discipline team, we formed
an instructional leadership team,
which consisted of
teachers who I knew were--
had best practices and were
implementing best practices
in the room.
And so I started building
the shared leadership,
and giving the staff members
ownership by forming the committees,
working together, because I
wanted them to see that it's not
about the leader telling
them what to do.
We have to own it as a staff.
>>The Care for Kids Program has
allowed a structure and a framework
for us to teach the
social, emotional,
intellectual components
for the children.
We were doing it, and trying our
best to do it, but the structure
of the morning meetings and the
afternoon meetings, and the resources
that we have, to really be
intentional about how we interact
with students, has definitely taken
it to-- took it to a whole new level.
Some teachers, the Care for Kids
might come naturally for them.
For others, it might
be more of a struggle.
The framework is there,
they can pick up the book,
and structure their morning
meeting and their afternoon meeting
and so forth, using the resources.
And so it's helped everyone quickly
be able to implement it successfully,
consistently, school-wide.
We've been able to do it, and
I've noticed the interactions
between students and also
between the teachers and students,
the interactions are more positive.
>>I make it a point to be
in a morning meeting
every day, to participate.
That's one way I can get to know the
kids, but I also want the teachers
to know that I value the
program, because they have to--
it has to come from me, and showing
that this is a valuable program,
we believe in it, so I'm
always in a morning meeting,
and then I do walk throughs daily,
in classrooms, because that's one way
that we can help move our school
forward, is if I'm in there,
I'm observing, interacting
with the students.
I will ask the students,
tell me what you're learning,
why is this important?
They need to know how to
articulate their learning.
So that's one thing I look for, and
then I'm looking at instruction,
and providing feedback to the
teachers on areas of growth,
and we've built this culture where
they are-- they accept feedback,
they want to improve, or they want
to know how they can help
a child be successful.
>>It's just so rewarding
when I have visitors come in,
substitutes come in, and they
have-- always comment about the kids
and how they seem happy, and
wanting to learn, and really wanting
to do their best, and we have put a
lot of the learning on the students.
When we talk about, we conference
with students on their work,
and on their assessments.
They set individual learning
goals, so they have it--
they want to do well for
them, rather than just for us.
And it's something that we
have to constantly work on,
but we're putting a lot of
ownership on the students,
and so that they become
lifelong learners.
>>Learning cannot occur until you
have a safe environment, and that--
no matter what academic program
you put in place, if you don't have
that environment where students
feel safe, and they're willing
to take risks, and you have
the relationships built,
learning will not occur.
And so I would tell any
principal that that's what--
when you think about trying
to raise your test scores,
and all the requirements,
that won't happen
if the students aren't
able to take risk.
Our students want to do well,
they want to do well for us,
and then they want to
do well for themselves.
They are proud of the school, and so
they want to do well, which, in turn,
it helps with achievement scores,
it pays off in the long run,
it really pays off if you set that,
you have that environment
for learning.
Our teachers can teach now,
and students can learn,
because they feel safe.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org